hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
official but I call it the third trailer
for the HBO series Watchmen excuse me if
I seem a little bit out of it right now
I have some really bad stomach pains I
went to go watch hustlers with me lady
last night and it's one of two things
that are making me feel really sick it
was either the popcorn because I only
had a fourth of it or was the
subconscious Catholic guilt of enjoying
hot ladies while I'm sitting next to my
girlfriend shame shame speaking of shame
guys you should go check out her patreon
page over there we do weekly Q&A s and
we also do TV o SoDo TV show reaction
stream alongs for many shows that's
where you could sync up with a timecode
those are Cobra Kai season 2 haunting of
Hillhouse season 1 goth ham made it's a
season three so far stranger things
season 3 agents of shield and then there
are several shows where we do reaction
highlights with footage included four
and also have the option to stream along
and those are attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood my hero academia
movie included Death Note Code Geass
watch hunter hunter and supernatural
serum
[Music]
like no one nice
it's a kind of song that would be on an
HBO trailer up yeah they got their brand
[Music]
from the Incredible Hulk it's chapter 2
so it's also exposing like one tab yes
Carnival of the other dope amazing
mirrors sex
it looks like it yeah
[Music]
well if that's shot in that other
trailer were dr. Manhattan picks up the
mask isn't dr. Manhattan play I got a
little like furs a hot second where I
got a little pulled out when I was
watching this cuz I was thinking that's
pretty cool I mean there's some stuff
that feels like natural continuation in
some way we're the Watchmen I'm gonna go
off the movie unless the graphic novel
we're The Watchmen movie and because
it's easily could they could just
advertise this in the way of just only
pure nostalgia and in a lot of ways I
felt like I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
that's two days in a row for me man are
you gonna do you gotta fix this
I just got throw out my phone this one
seemed to be the most that highlighted
getting you more invested or interested
in the newer characters and this time
around instead of going like where's no
no where's dr. Manhattan yeah I mean
Watchmen it was like a cool
deconstruction of sorts I feel like
there's been a lot of movies and and a
lot of shows actually especially within
the DC Universe I've just made it to the
second to last season of arrow there
even like major deconstruction of Oliver
Queen as arrow and what it means to be a
vision like that and daredevil did it
too like there's a lot of shows that
already explored a lot of this concept
that's talked about primarily in the
first part of this trailer so I was
watching you know like oh that's cool
but I feel like I've been seen that done
a lot already this yeah and it's weird
to see something that is a fresh
adaptation of something that has
influenced so many other things because
the watchmen graphic novel has arguably
influenced all those things that have
now come in cinema before this
adaptation of watchmen sure so I do
wonder one of the biggest things I
wonder is how they will basically react
to that because I remember seeing 300
rise of an empire and thinking to myself
well 300 begat all these like Spartacus
type TV shows and now the sequel feels
like those shows yeah and that's kind of
what I hope they can avoid here and it
seems like they prop
can I think there's a reason why there's
three trailers because this is the first
trailer to make me think about that
yes I really I really enjoyed the other
two trailers lot and I enjoyed this
trailer too as well that was just one
thought that popped into my head the
other thought that popped in my head
what do people really want from this
series like how can you keep people
happy with this show exactly this is all
things the writers are at retain Damon
Lindelof and team have composed for us
you know this is not based off of any
specific source material other than
continuing the original source material
you know crash up some of those ideas
into their new ideas and then they want
to make a show which is multiple
episodes so like what tone what pacing
what somatic exploration what would keep
people satisfied with this series you
know my one concern that I have with
this show we've been like super positive
about this right so I figured why not
dive into some why not trash this yeah f
you HBO that's right even though I pay
you like 20 bucks a month no I'm kidding
mr. HBO Jeff Age these concerns that I'm
having I'm worried that the creators
will be thinking about this when they're
making this series Watchmen is sensitive
material and the way people responded to
the movie wasn't the most enthusiastic
while I think it's grown appreciation
over time especially zack snyder's
director's cut looks like they're kind
of doing their own thing it's but I
lifted it with a surprise me was this is
all within like one city it looks like
yeah one town I'm never watching mean a
lot bigger you know yeah and I think to
make it more contained more character
focus more media with the current
situation they're dealing with is
Rorschach called this American Horror
Story looking do well the thing is the
difference to me at least from the movie
to this seems like they're concentrating
more on the people closer to the line
between the civilian and hero because
the thing that was sort of exciting
about Watchmen the movie other than the
deconstruction was oh look you got the
comedian you got a knight Alan you got
Sally Jupiter and you got all these big
hero types and you have Regina
and you have a couple you know a hero
looking characters you have also you
know Ozymandias who's older now and
stuff but it seems like the focus or at
least I maybe hope the focus is yeah in
the very thin line between justice and
mania and you know the the people on the
ground versus the more out there heroes
yeah and I think expanding and telling a
story that's much you no longer a series
yeah it's a good place to do that and
the biggest thing I learned from the
last trailer reaction is that Damon
Lindelof I guess has kind of redeemed
himself in the public eye especially
since a lot of donors yeah Brad Regina
King in it yeah so um that alone kind of
gives me another curiosity and some hope
that they can follow the crowd
well Fashion Island a la fere life won't
for years people been like Damon
Lindelof he's got all these great setups
he's like no wonder he works with JJ
Abrams doesn't get finished things but
now you know it sounds like well I'm
rooting for anybody to improve and and I
think that the this money coming out
Hustler's now Mike you yeah and then
ruin all the equipment and I'll teach
you a real lesson about busting up my
flow ryan johnson made a couple of
really amazing things and then he made a
last jedi and did his own thing run away
with they're gonna have to be very
respectful of that source material for
sure yeah watchmen oh god I love this
tagline on the poster and I maybe
nothing ever ends that's a great that's
there's some irony there's some sad
literally in making this we are
confirming nothing ever ever and that's
true even something I think the Creator
wishes alright guys what are you sad for
Watchmen should we cover this will
decide
you guys can't subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell as
you can check us on page from where we
got good he's patron of the day shout
out for a man named Philip J Smith jr.
ooh Philip is probably the most
tradition
who has ever embarked on a patron shout
out for us
keeps his words short he's really
straight to the point this man his dad
worked on computers he has a local
government gig volunteer firefighter he
doesn't even know what YouTube is dude
ya know what YouTube is somehow he found
his way to our patreon yeah dad fix
computers and this was the first website
the pilot yeah like how do I check out
what's on patreon.com slash the real
rejects all right I was silent I guess
I'll give 15 bucks I say ask your local
government job for more hours this way
you can increase your pledge then you
could pledge to John's personal Patriot
that's right what do you do there John
I just sing people's songs about them
let's write a little five-minute ditty
and it's all improvised yes watch Philip
J Smith jr. what a wonder you're here
you work for the government which means
your pledge is funded by the man yeah
technically that's the government giving
us 15
no he's via you $200 only $200 a song
one but you you got that just really
take a long time